"Quotes are pewds."
"Ok here we are farty pants is joining the party"
"no-ho."
"oh, I wonder who."
*BEEP BEEP BOOP BZZZZ*
"Ha ha ha ha, hehh."
""Oh man okay cool if we're gonna go with Professor Chaos- Hey, hey is that a brofist?"
"yeah, that's a brofist ah"
"That's a put a pewdiepie reference that has to be a pewdiepie. Yes top bad guys"
"Heh haha ha heehh."
"I've been away for a few days. I haven't been able to play I was celebrating birthdays and stuff"
"But I'm really happy to be back and playing cuz this game is so fun"
"There was no break for you guys, so don't worry. Actually probably was"
"well anyway"
"We got to meet up with Professor chaos"
"Well isn't this great we get to spend some time talking to you there we go"
"Fine!"
"Excuse me, I am NOT a boy, okay."
"I'm a Scandinavian."
"Swede a Mian."
"Oh no."
"Yeah, how do we reply?"
"Nooooooo!"
"Wait you can't gr-"
"oh"
"Sure buddy "borrowing""
"Gather the flying minion ingredients get the superhero figurine cape get the rock, okay, okay?"
"Well that was easy..."
"OOOOOOOOOOHHHoh ho ho oh my god."
"Guess we can't do that, Jebus"
"Sure buddy."
"What is this then?"
"My god be quiet, please."
"There we go, now I can grab it. "
"What else we need, the hamster, that shouldn't be hard, right?"
"All right now we got to craft the flying min- What in the world...
"Oh its so cute, oh my god!"
"Okay, we have the flying minion what can he do though?"
"'Escape butters house'"
"I'm a little worried about this"
"How do we escape?"
"Hold L2 - okay, okay, so we can do something now."
"We get a lot of these"
"So he will fly up and bite the wires."
"No no oh no no"
"No no I say no, I said no no"
"Why..."
"Just why?"
"Couldn't you just have thrown him up?"
"Whoopee indeed."
"My butt can do all kinds of cool"
"Stuff finally my butt is getting recognized for its true talent and potential. Thank you. Oh"
"There's a safe. oh."
"We can use"
"Hay wire here yeah alright okay  okay"
"Just gotta text our hamster."
This is so weird
"Did i not do it right? I guess I gotta stick in another one, hold down. I was doing it!"
"There you go"
"Does that mean ha ha ha all right now bye"
"OH OH ho ho."
"A wrestling photo"
"That's what that was yes, of course"
"Can't seem to walk here for some reason there we go"
"What we got something else didn't we? A new artifact perhaps"
"Think it's time, some of these are outdated aren't they"
"Whoa look at that. We're really strong now"
"Ok alright, okay okay okay."
"Butters Dad are we gonna fight him? nice."
"Defeat butters dad all right we get the whole team here cool."
"Wow your buddies can't join the fight until you unground them. The ability to unground has replaced your ultimate power in this fight"
"Oh"
"What?"
"Okay, well let's start off. Oh no I don't oh. I see I can use it whenever I want."
"There you go, you're ungrounded I used my dark black magic"
"Oh no not double grounded please."
Shoot. He has a lot of health.
"How many times do I got to tell you"
"My gah... Okay, I can't walk there"
"Let's just unground these guys. Alright lets unground the coon"
"Don't know if we can actually get out of here. Oh, we can we can switch places Coon has that ability"
"This might sting"
"Damn, good damage, too."
"Ah so dumb."
"I need to use my ult."
"Was that a PewDiePie reference?"
"Oh my god."
"Wow I"
"Don't believe it"
"Okay alright okay okay, we're gonna keep using this one."
"Coon's gonna get grind-eh, ground, grinded, grounded damn it."
"How is he not dead yet, okay, he's dead now there you go, thank God we got him grounded"
"For life!"
"Nooooooooo!"
"That was fun. Fun fight"
"We really messed up this place didn't we?"
"We gotta go to tokens house, I don't know if we should go back there"
"Okay, he's supposed to be x-men. Okay. Let's go to his- okay okay okay"
"Okay, okay lets go. dark meadow. Here we go. I did. What's up?"
"This is just tokens house. What do you mean?"
"Aw yeah, we can use..."
"Well no we we hack it, but okay, whatever you say. I have to stand over here for some reason."
"Well that's messed up"
"I feel bad."
"Hey, that's kinda cool."
"Wonder Tweek!"
"Oh my god!"
"How does he understand?"
"What is he working on?"
"Alright so we joined the freedom pals now."
"That's right Freedom Pal does do they have a shop? here's one? Mac five nice.
"Training room, what goes on in the training room? It's just a room glad. We glad we did that
"We can buy outfits. Viper suit."
"The Viper one is cool, then you know what? lets go Viper."
"Aw these are all cool. Damn it"
"Look at that. is that not dope huh?"
"No stupid, how dope is that huh?"
"All stupid makeup."
" He looks like Kenny a little bit."
"I have this weird urge to protect you..."
"That's the social justice warrior in ya buddy, real proud of you. Meet the freedom palace at the South Park Senior Center"
"Okay, okay, all right. Let's check it out"
"We're probably gonna have to beat up some old people, but you know what I say old people might as well be..."
"Not."
"Living."
"That came out a little weird okay. There we are, Member?!
"I catch up on South Park yesterday that it's still so good man."
"Yes."
"Thank you..."
"Oh my god..."
"Bling!"
"Dude I'm killing it at the triangle."
"Oh my god..."
"Oh, oh, I should have seen that coming."
"Why am I enjoying this?"
"Yeah, what'd I tell you? We gotta, gotta kill some old people."
"This is a- okay, it's a special objective. It should be fine. What are they gonna do knock us back?"
"Oh no!"
"Ugh he's so annoying."
"A Jewish scroll?
"Oh great, let's try this..."
"Pretty powerful"
"We have this"
"That's right old people"
"That's a strong one"
"No, EW EW EW EW."
"They're all making me grossed out, I don't like this."
"Thank you."
"Oh, that was easy..."
"Well I might just- I might just tell some people."
"I don't know why I'm loyal to the Coon friends."
"But I guess- I guess this is the way the cookie crumbles"
"Is this on? Okay dear ButtLord stop recent triangle playing of- what?"
"What in the world..."
"Okay, we got to go back to coon lair"
"You know when someone says they're gonna do something and you think you can trust him"
"But then they don't and they're super lame instead?' 'Don't sub Grab me dick.'."
"Thank you."
"We gotta help, PAY the minions..."
"Should we do that? Let's do that."
"Can we fast travel?"
"Yes, we can... Gotta go fast!"
These loading screens are intense, man. I've wished more and more. I played on PC man but goddamn..."
Is that our tail it looks like a poop whatever alright here, we are at the bank. Oh, yeah, we gotta use our butt-lord."
"Okay"
"Real superpowers look at that no fake-ass superpowers. Sorry one second. My dogs just escaped."
"Let's check out the bank."
"What?!"
"Come on, come on, come on."
"Skills in i- skills stop the wheel"
"What in the world?"
"Is happening?"
"I guess we keep spinning..."
"Just don't get bankrupt, don't get bank- ooh close."
"Skill stop the wheels, press to stop no whammies. Insider trading."
"Whoa!"
"We're in low class now!"
"Look at that we're rich, man."
"What in the world was that, can we play again, that was fun."
"That w-was a good- it was a- fuck."
"I saw the poster."
"That's right, they take ur jubs."
"We're mad for merry-v-very." (Idk wtf.)
"Okay, that make sense. All right. Let's just kick those guys asses."
"Whoa, what we can summon minions now. We can summon the Mexicans, that's awesome"
"Minions pretty good."
"That's a microaggression YEAH! How dare you say that."
"There's nothing wrong with being a minion, and they can still build stuff if they want to."
"Okay, all right you're a good tank you're a moi macho tank?"
"That hurt a little bit. Oh."
"A car and they're even in on it. I mean we did move, didn't we?"
"My god our minion's taking a lot of damage"
"Hey, we did it! Okay nice, we need to level up a little bit.""
"We're a bit under level, so it's good that we do these extra quests and stuff isn't that fun"
"This is what you want in life, okay?"
Good job reading between the lines that gentleman's clearly stereotypi- aw, what did it say? Damn it."
"Talk to the Coon in the Coon lair"
"Let's see if there's some more quests that we can do..."
"To level up a little bit, you know I'm saying?"
"You know I'm saying you know. I'm saying. Let's go to windy. She's close by anyway."
"My minions, and I will fight by your side any time, butthole hashtag chaos. Thank you for that hashtag."
"We haven't seen like anything too crazy yet, so I'm thinking maybe that's the stuff they save for the side quests. Oh god."
"I don't wanna..."
"Go to the appropriate bathroom. Oh, I see okay. All right. I think I know which one"
"Maybe?"
"No, but that's where I am! Oh no..."
"Wait this is a micro-aggression..."
"I know where that is."
"D Mobile."
"Because, they are, dicks."
"Here it is. Yeah, no, yes."
"No, that's my enemy!"
"Wow 5 gigabyte!"
"But crab people is my mortal enemy, this will be hard. No?"
"Man this is so brilliant, seriously any time you try and-"
"Just get a data plan. They always just put some weird stuff on you that you don't want."
"Well at least wendy's strong."
"Oh he has savings for us, how nice!"
"As long as the crab people don't touch us we might be okay."
"Ew, they're so disgusting I hate them."
"No no their manager. Oh!"
"Employee of the Month, manager king crab febuary."
" Oh damn dog, we got to defeat the king crap."
"But how he's too strong, it's impossible."
"Mobility is her strong- oh we can still attack it from here. We should probably finish him off first..."
"WE DOXXED!"
"Wow, oh wait he can summon. No, oh and he can heal as well."
"That's really bad for us!"
"Okay all right okay. They're really weak"
"Yeah, okay, I'm working on it. All right Wendy working on it there we go."
"Protect your managah, ah, crab people!"
"Damn."
"I'm working on it."
"Hopefully he can't heal himself."
"Just remember crab people is my mortal enemy."
"You will all die crab people."
"EW!"
"Yes! Screw those crab people. Screw them all teh hell..."
"That was fun, I'm glad."
"Will do wendy."
"And we can loot them. that doesn't happen. I love the side quests, this is so fun!"
"And there was lor- was that actually lord playing?"
*VERY HIGH PITCHED AND GAY*
All right, let's check out the coons lair. Enough, uh, fucking around.
"I mean enough chit chit chittling diddling around am I right?"
*WHISPERING*
"Christian channel please heh heh."
"It's right there, what's the passcode now? No girls allowed, okay."
"Did it!"
"Thank you."
"No, no, no, NO."
"NOOOOOOO."
"Nah"
"Let's do gadgeteer."
"Ok."
"I have MORE gadgets? My god. What is this a dummy?"
"Well that seems pretty useless."
"Oh i see."
"Oh it's one of those! Oh damn, that's pretty good."
"But now we have our ult."
"Okay, let's see how- what the ult does."
"It's a drone, nice."
"What about the alien, there buddy?"
"Okay."
ha ha
"Yes, we'll change into our costume, BUT in the next episode, thank you guys so much for watching another one."
"I hope you enjoyed it. I'll see you tomorrow, again. We're back on track daily. Sorry I missed one, but as always squad f-"